ME I WOULD LIKE TO BE ON THE
.
>> Gord: MAXIM MAMIN PLAYS
THAT DOWNRE.
GENERALLY THEY ARE.
>> Gord: FOUR GOALS A
WASHINGTON GOTTEN OFF TO
BADAT A RIDICULOUSLY AN
ABERRATION.
HAVE A LOT OF MOVING PARTS
. BYS
GOALSANGEROUS GAME, RIGHT.
IN COMES HER
I WILL SAY THIS, GORD, YOU
DIDN'T HAVE  OUTRNEY IS
GOING TO PICK UP A TRIP IN THE
POWER-PLAY TIME FOR FLORIDA.
GENERATES SOME LOOKS, BN 04/05,Y
THREE TEAMS HAVEN'T WONIT INTO .
STOPPED BY. MENTIONED THE ONE
SHOT ON THE POWER PLAY FOR
FLORIDA.
. SHOT.
GOES OFF THE STICK AND WIDE.HER.
GOT TO GET THAT PUCK OVER THE
BLUE LINE.
WHEN IT'S GOOD
FINDING GUYS..
PICKED UP BY NORRIS.
THE LAST MONTHS OR SO
THEY'VE BEEN REALLY THE
REAK.
HE PLAYED IN A FEW OF TH MAMIN.